hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome back to I guess the charrids
avenged adventures in Minecraft I
wouldn't really name this anything and
that is a creeper alright so I don't
even remember where we are we finished
because this is a completely new um
completely new day obviously I'm not
recording these in like sessions i'm not
actually this i'm just doing this to
take a break from studying so I mean
obviously there's going to be pretty
much once a day what is your special ad
so um last time I else you guys oh yeah
first of all someone suggested that I am
I putted monster opengl on I did
performance let's put to max FPS I don't
know that'll do but um we'll see if that
actually helps with the stuff frame rate
looks about the same but i'm not sure
why it's lagging for you guys maybe I'm
maybe I should tell fraps to record it a
lower frame rate I don't know I guess
we'll see we'll save this video turns
out interestingly um I gotta stop
talking and actually if this video does
up like a bit of a flag or whatever all
it'll drop the frame rate 234 perhaps I
can't see anything um okay just get out
here alright so I wanted like a beach
place but I don't think we'll be able to
find it uh right now like tonight just
because um there's that music again love
it all right
I kept thinking into the beiges towards
the Sun but I know it's not yeah all
right um all right so last time I asked
you guys if if you get to leave some
topics or questions for me to answer /
you know talk about and I'll be a be
answering some questions in a second be
talking on a few things and second um
just after I you know got myself out of
here okay you guys can't see anything
that I'm sorry I can barely see anything
so stopping me from jumping there we go
I just really do want to find it
actually suffer so many pumpkins I can
just do this Connor yeah and the Salam
give me much more light when I need it I
also don't have a sword for any kind of
air we go that's what I'm talking about
see Dad is what I'm talking about that's
what I was looking for where are we by
the way okay we're pretty close to spawn
actually all right ok so I can't hold
food crap i forgot about food completely
[ __ ] um it's a skeleton as well Oh grab
this a zombie all right let's stop some
light down in a minute just when i get
to light there we go um we're screwed
crap i didn't think about food at all my
food cuz health is going to start
running out and it will continue running
out all the way until I am until I die
is that cuz [ __ ] this is actually a
problem that's skeleton okay maybe I
should've left that place okay we've a
bit of a problem wrap um crap
crap cows cows give [ __ ] i'm actually in
huge trouble here because if I die the
world gets deleted Oh spawn tree you eat
this crap I'm dodging arrows right now
so yeah oh crap I gotta get on the
ground this just got a whole lot more
exciting okay chickens that's kind of
good I guess oh crap ah I've got to be
completely unpredictable I'm screwed
right now I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know where I'm going i'll get to
those questions and topics in a second
it's kind of an emergency situation what
oh crap and end uh end a man with a
slender man whatever Oprah ah absolute
oh oh okay i'm actually in a bit of a
pickle right now I'm just gonna dive on
the water [ __ ] and look at my food okay
this is actually gonna difficult okay
what do I have I've got a lot of storing
my back could build something out of
that like a shelter I gonna um oh crap
no I'm running I'm out of here I'm
abandoning this country until I can
actually find some some stuff okay where
am I going oh [ __ ] this is an emotion
this is just like oh crap alright well
hope you're enjoying this potentially
lost episode of this series because if I
die that's that's it that's the end if
you want it or not that looks nice
doesn't it yeah it doesn't
because then my other problem is like
food like it's not just as simple as
running away from this guy's I need to
find food okay but first I do need to I
do actually need to barricade myself in
here oh good all right I've got torches
so that's cool okay it's not much okay
all right i'm gonna start losing i'm
actually food sources guys I need a
fruit sauce i know i wanna die i want
half of freaking borrow food left what
can i eat con eight seeds what if I cook
seeds [ __ ] okay I can't okay food in
Minecraft and was literally googling
this right now I'm going to die
I'm not pausing the end like that's
cheating [ __ ] a chicken okay come on
literally this has to like lay me an
angle something if I Killick in it yeah
it could leave what how's that sound um
bread bread out of you how do you make a
good bread
oh crap chicken hang on check
chicken dip hang on
chickens drop oh my yet what chicken
shop watch it oh my goodness they do
drop chicken microbe has changed [ __ ] do
I have enough time helen is going to be
until I
like a furnace real quick oh my goodness
this is unbelievable I didn't know that
on his sword um a stick crap
oh ok but a sort of us or so good
where's that chicken yeah you are really
sorry but yes raw chicken holy crap i
just got food yes cook that beast that's
what I'm talking about chera is gonna
survive this haha yes all right Wow okay
that was intense
yes yes and look at my health like go to
my oh that's better all right I need
more more chicken god I didn't know the
chickens dropped I thought they ought to
do anything they drop it like feathers
and eggs eggs definitely it x I can run
now and like there are nizam bees around
this is perfect let me just reorganize
this real quick oh whoa i just heard
something what's what's growling at me I
gotta have to get out of here I have to
be like above half food right to
regenerate health is that how it works
or or what okay what can I make with
chromic with
I'm so scared some is not dropped down
on me
you
can I
we're going to make with eggs link bread
right now power not um
what does annette eggs all right
as my jack-o'-lantern right over there
the chicken egg
well I can make up
not many things actually I'm surprised
make a cake that's always good this
thing
pi line it is I just need sugar that's
all because I've already got those on
those pumpkins
sugar cane let's make girls make a
pumpkin pie I do love pumpkin pie but oh
my raw chicken hang on this game has
gotten a lot different since I last
fighter that's for sure
yeah well I saw her generating health
now come on god there's something down
below here they don't show numbers
anymore do that no if there is something
down below yeah it's very very dangerous
that I'll explore eventually there's a
skeleton still avoid them I don't have
any armor and I'm low on Alf go that
sound is killing me now sugar can I find
any of that because that's actually I
think pumpkin pie will give me I much
better than chicken is that it it's a
chicken all right no no see any sugar
can all right it's dawning we're going
to find some sugarcane we're going to
wow look at that thing we've got a
desert here as well I do like desert
stuff Wow listen they're scary all right
soils cooks
chicken and hopefully we'll start
generating health and
oh and we can um we can get on with
with our lives miles I was insane I have
to tell you that was insane you get like
experience as well and we better sorry
general health right now we're still
half a bother so we might need a now
we're ready health sweet all right well
I guess our first house
hopefully I'm the frame rate is and it's
likely this time as well Wow I'm just
admiring this place for aspiring over
there looks like it it's a desert and
this is I don't know just another
grasslands Lee um I'm gonna go pick in
that cave or another wow we got dark
that is is that ok good now it's just
unrendered chunks my bad all right we're
in full health that was really close
we've still got people underneath that
will probably explore but I'm sorry I
didn't get it to any of your questions
or topics this time but that was just
too that was too epic I couldn't I
couldn't like I had to I had to think so
if you have any topics all questions
that you want me to answer will talk
about in the next video go ahead and rob
a comment let me know and yeah i guess
i'll see you guys want a next take a
break from from studying so uh yeah let
it guys